ce blinder ukrainien avance rapidement
sur ce champ de bataille aux abords de
barboutte car il y a quelques jours à
peine les rues s'occupaient ce
territoire
ces soldats Ukrainiens déambulent sur
les quelques kilomètres qui ont été
reconquis selon qui est
qui selon des premières informations
quand on regarde l'ampleur de notre
avancée et le nombre de victimes russes
cette impressionnant
autour des tranchées russes cette
brigade trouve des anciens abris du
matériel abandonné et des morts un
repose sous ce drap blanc
nos hommes l'ont tué sûrement des
mortiers parce qu'il a beaucoup de
blessures il y a beaucoup de cadavres
il y en a trop
à quelques kilomètres de la ligne de
front ces soldats se reposent dans ce
bunker souterrain il reste vigilant la
Russie contrôle toujours la
quasi-totalité de barmut les récents
succès revendiqués par Kiev leur apporte
de l'espoir
nous savons ce que nous faisons nous
savons comment nous devons attaquer
comment nous devons nous défendre nous
savons qu'au bout du compte dans deux
trois ou cinq ans je ne sais pas nous
gagnerons cette guerre
reste l'épicentre des combats depuis des
mois bien que la date de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne reste
incertaine ces troupes l'attendent avec
impatience